you know the routine when there's rumors
of a good show I like getting cancelled
I talk about it community so you've
heard me compare some comedies to the
show community now I might as well
review community so community takes
place in a community college in which
case Joel McHale started out as the main
character but now it's kind of like
everybody's the main character Joel
McHale is the cool guy he used to be a
lawyer and he got his license taken away
so now he has to retake college and he
has to start out where anyone starts out
when they're trying to save money
Community College and from there you
have one of the most solid casts that
just works I mean you have this hippie
chick who kind of likes Joel McHale and
Joel McHale likes her but you know
they're both stubborn so they're not
going to admit it of the character she's
probably the most useless it just is
then you have Shirley who's the hardcore
Christian check which pretty much makes
all the Christmas episodes comedic fun
who really works well with Chevy Chase
who's the hardcore old racist he is he's
just like one of those old racist guys
where you're like did you just say that
I'm not gonna hate you for saying it cuz
you know you think it's the Year one I
couldn't say that but you just did being
old is always fun and Allison breeze in
it was a picture a little too
misogynistic okay fine
Allison breeze in it she plays the cute
chick who's kind of quirky and really
awesome when you find out Alison Brie
looks like Alison Brie my two favorite
characters in the entire show though
it's all leading up to this Troy and
Abed Abed's like autistic about movies
he knows everything movies he always
makes movie references he sees life as a
movie not surprising I like the guy and
Donald Glover plays Troy now Troy is
funny because in the very first episode
if you watch it Troy's like you know the
jock is really up on himself he's like
the knucklehead you know and they were
like Troy and Abed really work together
so we're just gonna make Troy another
movie geek like Abed Troy and Abed make
every episode just the best episode it
could possibly be because usually when
it comes down to Troy and Abed they will
reference TV shows 80s references 90s
references pop-culture references and
movie references Anthony Michael Hall
played a bully in a couple episodes a
bully and it was awesome because this
show clearly caters to nerds which is
probably why they changed up Troy from
the jock to the nerd because in a show
that caters to movie nerds they don't
care about jocks even as that one guy
you know the guy from The Hangover who
used to actually be a doctrine
life and he gave that up to do comedy he
did that that's real he is a Chinese
Spanish teacher named Senor Chang that's
just funny in itself there's just one
episode is all it's just a paintball
episode and it's absurd how they do it
because when you're landed in this
paintball scenario it looks like this
paintball war has been going on for
years and everyone's faction dawei and
they're all talking about survival they
got like paintball bullets like strapped
around their chest like Rambo my
favorite episode actually aired this
season and I don't want to tell you much
about it is one of those episodes if I
tell you about it it just ruins the
magic but it's the one where someone has
to go downstairs and get the pizza the
reason I bring this show up the reason
I'm professing that is one of the
funniest shows ever made and easily the
funniest show on TV right now in my
opinion every Parks and Recreation fan
is going to be like I'm just saying in
my opinion it's because the show was put
on hiatus and the rumor is that it's in
danger of being cancelled it's in its
third season I'd like to see it at least
finish a fourth season you have four
seasons of college I would personally
love to see six seasons in a movie which
is how a band says it should happen but
six seasons of community college it
probably would not be role models
anymore for anyone so I say check this
show out you can buy season one on DVD
for like 20 bucks I don't know how much
season 2 is probably around 20 bucks I'm
telling you every episode in community I
laugh really hard and I profess this is
the funniest comedy on TV likeable
characters great characters that work
together with great chemistry smart
writing and references that I love
because I'm a movie fan if you're a
movie fan you will like community I
promise Abed's birthday episode the
entire episode was dedicated to pulp
fiction that is awesome so have you seen
community what do you think of it and
what is your favorite comedy on TV
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
you
[Music]